unhelpful advice Bobby then love each
other then make out and make eye contact
and a [ __ ] my problem is that I feel
like my girlfriend has given up on me
trying to stay fit
we are 21 years old and she is not fat
but she is definitely chubby and has
over the past few years been getting
chubbier I try to stay in shape and work
out regularly and when I invited her to
come exercise she what she chooses not
to I thought that our appearance is only
going downhill where's me because I'm in
it for the long haul I've been making
her when she eats unhealthy and
occasionally take her on hikes but is
there anything effective I can say or do
to get her to change her habits I really
love her and we'd hate and would hate to
weaken our relationship if I lose
attraction to her thanks you guys Chris
oh if you really love her dude like get
off her back about it
it's just let her do what she wants with
her body it's like it's like saying hey
with Bobby if I want him to get healthy
it's because I want him to be healthy
not I don't if he could keep this big
belly of his and not be diabetic and
live a very long life I'd be like yeah
keep the belly I don't care what you
look like
can't you do that medically I mean I
think there are some thicker people who
are perfectly healthy but if you're
saying you know you want her to change
the way she looks I think you need to
look into yourself more than look into
her flaws like you have some growing up
to do because but it's inevitably people
are never gonna stay the same you're
gonna get older and when you look at
like old couples you think I mean
there's no way to look at like your wife
who's like 80 and go yeah no but you go
I love this woman she was she's been
there with the whole time and there's
something deeper if she's your person
dude it doesn't matter what shape she
comes in she's a person and you might be
imposing all this like health and
exercise stuff that you're doing
creaking yeah create an internet porn I
mean did your golf it's it's the same
way like if I told him you know I'd
leave him because he's gained you know
10 pounds or 20 pounds he's getting
chubbier and chubby but if he got 600
pounds I'd be like broilers a problem
like
go to a TV show yeah I mean I'd I'm
wiping your ass every day you can barely
get out of bed that's a problem but if
she's happy with yourself like how dare
you tell her how to be if she likes the
way she looks if she's all you can be
there is if she's ready to be like babe
I want to be healthy and I want to
actually lose weight then you could be
like yeah let's go to the gym together
but don't impose that [ __ ] on her if
she's happy with herself
you should be happy with who she is
check yourself bro
whoa no dude I mean he's being honest
it's an honest thing I asked myself the
same question would I be with somebody
who I started off like Brad Pitt and all
of a sudden he's gained 80 pounds and
I'm like [ __ ] like yeah it probably I
would probably be less attracted to them
sexually but if you think about it in a
long haul he says he's in it for the
long home like you really stopped
looking at your partner sexually after
three years anyways just wait out the
three years sorry babe I just don't look
at you
give your opinion to this guy he needs
it Bobby I just think that it's it's I
just said it's inevitably that she's not
gonna stay sexy forever neither are you
neither are you dude are you know yeah
you it she better be someone that you
can talk to that you can [ __ ] just
enjoy your silent moments with it's like
I like my fatty over here whoa
we were watching a movie last night with
snuggle love you watch a movie and you
cuddle and it's nice to be there you
know with the with your your partner
mm-hmm
that's good there's really no way to
tell her either it just sounds arrogant
when you tell a 21 year old girl hey
like well how was she
he's 21 I think all the [ __ ] probably
around the same age that's uncalled for
look you got to look good for them
before 25 look good no I thought you
were talking about they're in the 40s
no there's children no
No gee you got to get our leave leave
her exactly yeah I would rather go
listen you're 21
okay you should have been looking like
that and there are other 21 year-olds
that I could be having so you better
[ __ ] get on the [ __ ] pot or [ __ ]
or something how dare you how dare you
know what he should do is if he knows
he's losing attraction just spare her
just be like okay dude like I'm
obviously going through a very
superficial time in my life not
superficial slowly watch you should look
21 yeah but what does 21 look like I'll
show y'all google it you were the
[ __ ] stud at 21 I know but that's why
I had to do extra [ __ ] I've already been
telling that all cut the whole time the
whole time I was born you know I didn't
win a genetic lottery alright so maybe
this girl didn't but what's it to her if
she's dating or in the first place if
you were never yeah if it's a problem
with you do L is for the way you look
everything's fine oh you know I'm just
kidding
lover if it's just love we don't know
the answer it's just love guys it's love
I mean for me my relationships would
like my Christine write it it wasn't the
right fit
mm-hmm and I think that's the key right
it's a christina was young cute you know
she's cute or whatever but I just with
her when I just I feel things when I
look at kalila still today sometimes
it's not positive things vitriol no it's
like she just does you know maybe like I
feel these days you know you know but
those things are healthy I believe
they're not feelings of murder their
feeling is that what you know that whole
thing you know but it's like you need to
feel like when I was she was what we
went to the dog park today and she was
walking in front of me
was looking at I love her legs and the
way her legs look you know with the dog
legged I know but I like it it's like
this visual sense of like ah you know
you gotta have little moments like that
[Music]